NBA MVP Joel embiid is arguably the best
basketball player on the planet and for
that some of the credit goes to YouTube
and beat says that he relied on in his
words internet videos of regular white
people shooting three pointers to
understand the mechanics of hitting a
long distance shot it worked out pretty
well for him on top of being a big guy
who can dominate near the rim and bead
has a career three-point shooting
percentage that's better than Michael
Jordan's maybe you or I won't become a
professional basketball player by
watching YouTube but we might learn how
to fix a car or repair a toilet when
politicians call for regulating social
media and other online platforms they
risk throwing out a lot of the good with
the bad often in the name of protecting
children they ought to consider the
other side of that equation too being
exposed to unfamiliar ideas can
sometimes be scary but like it was for
16 year old Joel embiid as he tried to
refine his untapped athletic potential
it can also be game changing